ils sont venus à alerter les pouvoirs
publics face à l'augmentation de la
cotisation foncière des entreprises des
entrepreneurs se sont mobilisés ce mardi
devant le siège de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à trappes
ils demandent que soient recalculé cet
impôt fixé par les collectivités
territoriales et qui remplace la taxe
professionnelle
vous avez par exemple une petite
entreprise un commerce qui nous
signalent qu'ils ont ils passent de
environ 500 euros à quelque chose à 4
4000 euros par exemple des choses comme
ça donc ce qui est dans un budget du
nand une peu de tout petit peu tpe de
cette nature quelque chose d'extrêmement
pénalisant la confédération générale des
pme est à l'initiative de rassemblement
le but de la mobilisation obtenir le
retour au montant de 2011 à une heure on
parle beaucoup de la compétitivité des
entreprises qui est effectivement le
sujet central dans la gestion de nos
entreprises d'un point de vue de notre
économie
il est évident qu'un tel impôt dont la
hauteur aujourd'hui est très variable
suivant les entreprises dont on nous
avons nous même du mal à comprendre
quelles sont les clés de calcul augmenté
de 20% pour les plus petits jusqu'à 500
600 % pour les plus grosses
augmentations c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement pénalisant pour les
entreprises
donc il est bien évident que nous ne
pouvons que demander le retour à 2011
du côté de l'agglomération on cherche
une solution pour calmer la fronde
on est bien conscient que pour certains
de l'entreprise petites entreprises en
difficulté ça pose problème devoir
découvrir cette application de la taxe
pro c est de cette façon là c'est pour
ça que on a pris une délibération que le
gouvernement nous permet de prendre pour
revoir cette application de cette
nouvelle taxe
tsf sur les petites entreprises
cette délibération prévoit que les
entreprises auront jusqu'au 15 décembre
pour s'acquitter du même montant que
celui payé en 2011 les conditions de
paiement seront définies lors du vote du
budget de l'agglomération mardi 18
décembre en fin d'après midi ce mardi
les entrepreneurs ont été reçus en
délégation par le président de la
communauté d'agglomération